hi everyone
welcome to another video on the python
series of videos by simply loan
today we are going to look at scopes and
arguments in python
now you need to know the basics of
python functions to understand this
topic we already have a video on python
functions so please check that out
now let's learn about
what is scope in python
so scope in python is the area of the
region of a program where you can access
variables functions and objects declared
the scope defines the accessibility of
the python object so the objects cannot
be accessed from anywhere in the program
variables are not visible to the entire
code so their visibility can be
restricted
now scope verifies which variable to be
accessed
a variable declared inside a function
belongs to the local scope of that
function and can only be used inside
that function
now whenever you use a name such as a
variable name or a function name python
will search through different scope
levels or namespaces to determine
whether the name exists or not
so python resolves names using the legb
rule the legb stands for local
enclosed global and built-in scope
now talking about local scope the
variables which are defined in the
function are called local scope of the
variable so these variables are defined
in the function's body
now talking about
enclosing scope
now this scope only exists for nested
functions if the local scope is an inner
or nested function then the enclosing
scope is the scope of the outer or
enclosing function
coming to
global scope
the variable which can be accessed from
anywhere in the program is known as the
global scope such variables can be read
inside or outside the function
now the global scope is often
implemented when we want to use the same
variable name in the rest of the program
coming to the
final rule which is b that is built in
scope so if a variable is not defined in
local enclosed or global scope then
python looks for it in the built-in
scope now this scope contains names such
as keywords functions exceptions and
other attributes that are built into
python
now if you define the same variable name
inside and outside of a function python
will treat them as separate variables so
two separate variables one available in
the global scope that is outside the
function and the other available in the
local scope that is inside the function
now let's head over to our jupiter
notebook and we'll try
scopes in python with hands-on
demonstrations
all right so i'm on my jupyter notebook
let's start with our
examples first we'll look at
local scope in python
for that i am going to create a function
called
fun
and
inside the function i will create a
variable called
s which
holds let's say
an object called
simply loan
and then
i am going to
print
the variable that is s
now in this case i have defined my
variable
inside the function so this becomes
accessible only
inside the function
now if i call the function using the
function name that is f u n
and if we run it you can see we have the
message printed that is simply known
now
we'll see another example
so suppose
we'll try to access it outside the
function it will throw an error so i'll
just give a comment try
to access
it
outside the function
all right
so again i'll create
a function called let's say
fun 1
i'll give a colon and here i'll say
let's say
s1 equal to simply loan
and now
i'll give a comment here print s1
then i'll call my function
f u n 1
and
i'll try to
print
the variable s1
outside the function so here s1
has a local scope since it is defined
inside the function but i am trying to
access the variable outside the function
let's run it
you can see the error here name s1 not
defined
now
if i give a
comment
and run this
you see there is no message and let me
just remove this comment and print it
you can see we have the
s1 variable message printed that is
simply known so this is how the
local scope of a function works
now let's see an example of
enclosed scope which is
function inside another function
so i'll create a function
let's say func
and
i'll use the variable this time s2 equal
to
simply loan
and then
inside the func function i will define
another function let's say
i n func which basically stands for
inside
function and then here i'll say print s
s2
and
we'll call the
inner function that is in
fu and c
and then i'll call the outer function
let's run it
and see the result
you can see here we have the message
printed
simply learn i just
edit this message let's say
welcome to simply loan
now if i run this
you can see we have updated the message
here
now
for the enclosed scope you need to
define an outer function including the
inner function like we
did here
and you can also comment out the local
variable of the inner function and refer
to the variable using the non-local
keyword let me show you an example
around this
suppose i have a
global variable called msg
i'll see this is a
global
scope
message
after that
i'll create a function so i'll define a
function called
outer
and
i'll use the same variable name that is
msg
and my message would be this is an
outer variable
after that
i'm going to define another function
called
inner
and
this will have
the same variable that is msg and my
message would be
inner
message
variable
now as i mentioned before i need to
comment out the
local variable of the inner function so
i'll just
comment this out
and then
i'm going to say
non-local which is the keyboard
so i am
referring to the variable using the
non-local keyword
i'll say non-local
variable name that is msg
and now
i'll
print msg
will come out of the function and we'll
call it
inner
after that we'll call the
outer function
and then i'm going to print i'll just
scroll this down
and we'll say msg
so here what we are doing is so this is
an example of an enclosed scope so where
we have
defined the outer function enclosing the
inner function and we have commented out
the local variable of the inner function
and we are referring to the variable
using the non-local keyboard now let's
run it you see here i have
my
two
print statements working here the first
one is this is an outer variable you can
see here and then i have print msg so
this is a global scope message cool
now
we'll see an example of how the global
scope works though we have already seen
an example above so this was an example
of a global
scope
now we'll see a few more examples around
global scope again
suppose i have a variable called s3
equal to i'll see
simply loan
and then i'll declare a function
f unc
one
i give a colon and then say
print
s three
now i'll call the function f u n c one
and will print it
s3
if i run it you can see here i have
simply learned printed twice so i have
used the same variable name s3
inside the function so
this simply learn is for the
local scope s3 that is this one and
outside the
function we have printed s3 again so
simply learn twice
all right
now let me show you another example
about using the
global scope
create a variable msg1
let's say my message is
welcome to
simply learn
python
programming
i'll define the function func 2 i'll
give a colon
and i'll use the same variable that i
used
or declared above that is msg1
i'll say this is the
inner msg1 variable
then i'm going to print
msg1
after that i'll call my function func 2
and i'll print
msg1
if i run this
you can see i have the two messages
printed first is this is the inner mst1
variable and the second print statement
will print the
global variable
message that is welcome to simply learn
python programming
cool
now you can also
use the global keyword inside the
function to convert a local scope into
global scope
now
i'll just give a comment using
global keyword
so i'll define my function func let's
say 3
i'll give a colon
and using the global keyword
i'll say
s
and i'll say s equal to
simply loan
now let me
call func 3
and will print s outside the function
now one thing to remember here
my variable has been declared inside the
function but since before declaring the
variable i have assigned the global
keyword to s
so this now becomes a
global scope variable so you can access
it outside the function as well now if i
run it you can see it here i have my
message printed
simply on if i say hello you can see it
hello printed
cool
now
we'll see another example of using the
global scope
let's say i have a variable called a1
which is
india
and then
i'll create a function called my country
and i'll use
the
global keyword and say a1
and after that
i'm going to
say a1 equal to
i'll change the country to let's say
france
now let me
call the function my country
and will print
a1
and you can
notice the difference in the result so
here initially i had defined india as a
global variable and after that i am
assigning the
same variable name with a global keyword
and hence it will take
the updated value for e1 and you can see
here the result is france
now finally let's look at
built-in scope in python
this is the final example in the demo
session about scopes and arguments in
python
cool
so
this example is a bit different from the
previous few examples that we saw on
local scope
enclosed scope and global scope
so here
i am going to
import
pi from the math
module so i will say from math
import
pi
so this example includes
global scope enclosed scope as well as
local scope and of course we have the
built-in scope as well
now what i'll do is first i'll
give a comment and
create a variable called
pi
equal to
i'll say
global
pi
variable
i'll say this is a global
pi variable
and then
what i'll do is i'll say
df
let's do one thing first of all we'll
remove
the comment
and now i'll create a
outer function
into a colon and say
the variable pi
i'll say
outer
variable
pi
and then
i'll create
a nested function with the name inner
and
i'll say pi
equal to
inner
by variable
now
i am going to say
print
pi
and
after that i'll
call the
inner function
and
next
i'll also call the
outer function
now if i
run this
you can see the result
inner
pi variable being printed which is this
print statement
now
what i'll do is
i'm going to comment out the
global scope variable
and i'll also comment out
the first
outer function variable that i defined
i'll comment this out
and i'll also comment the inner
function
pi variable
now
if i run this
you see the result here it prints the
value of pi that was imported directly
from the math module or the math library
so here pi is not defined in either
local
enclosed or
global scope so the built-in scope is
looked up that is the pi value imported
from the math module so this is an
example of built-in scope in python that
uses
inbuilt
functions modules and objects that are
available in python
all right
so that brings us to the end of this
video tutorial on python scopes and
arguments i hope this video was useful
and informative if you have any queries
please feel free to put them in the
comments section of the video thank you
for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here